han pasado 20 años el Museo Nacional de
Irak ha reabierto sus puertas y sin
embargo las cicatrices del mayor saqueo
de su historia son aún muy visibles
objetos desaparecidos en su totalidad o
por partes piezas restauradas del 10 al
12 de abril de 2003 las colecciones
fueron saqueadas decenas de miles de
objetos de civilizaciones milenarias
robados como esta estatua a Siria
cuando la trasladaron le dañaron el codo
esta pieza fue robada y unir aquí se
enteró de que estaba a la venta
la compró barata en 2003 Y la guardó en
su casa hasta que se calmó la situación
en las calles iraquíes luego la devolvió
al museo
según las estimaciones de la época se
robaron 15.000 piezas Aunque ahora se
considera que están infravaloradas más
de 2000 piezas fueron devueltas en 2003
gracias a un programa de amnistía
iniciado por las estadounidenses tras la
caída del régimen de San José Inn pero
el resto del tesoro arqueológico se
sigue buscando en el mercado negro
Incluso en casas de subasta de todo el
mundo donde a menudo se falsifican los
documentos de identificación
estamos obligados por un acuerdo
internacional a recuperar objetos
a través de la UNESCO o interpole
la dificultad la encontramos en
demostrar que pertenecen a Irak cuando
han sido expuestos o numerados en el
Museo es fácil recuperarlos pero cuando
son robados o desenterrados ilegalmente
de yacimientos arqueológicos es
problemático porque tenemos que
demostrar que nos pertenecen
Este es el núcleo del problema del
control del tráfico de antigüedades
iraquíes el país con una historia
milenaria cuenta con más de 100.000
yacimientos arqueológicos muchos de
ellos En zonas remotas y de difícil
acceso objetivos perfectos para los
contra estas décadas de guerra y la
llegada de daesh han acentuado este
tráfico facilitado por las redes del
crimen organizado y la corrupción que
socaba el país la hemorragia parece
imposible de frenar este departamento de
policía lucha contra el régimen
organizado está especializado en
encontrar antigüedades robadas Esta es
la primera moneda es negra con cuatro
personas grabadas una de ellas con
cabeza de animal una gacela si la moneda
es autentificada el contrabandista se
enfrenta a una pena de hasta 10 años de
prisión se infiltran en las redes de
reventa de artefactos siendo apoyados
por agentes repartidos por todo el país
pudieron detener al sospechoso y
fragante y gracias a una trampa tendida
con el apoyo del juez estaba en posesión
de las monedas que pretendía vender el
objetivo de la venta de este patrimonio
es obviamente ganar dinero estas
antiguas fueron encontradas y
desenterradas por el sospechoso que
quería cambiarlas Por 20 mil dólares
la precaria situación económica del país
donde cuarta parte de la población vive
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza hace
especialmente urgente la protección de
estos lugares en agarguf cerca de Bagdad
muros y bayas rodean el emblemático
figura pero las autoridades reconocen
que los recursos humanos son demasiado
limitados para aplicarlo en todas partes
el número de empleados no es suficiente
para controlarlo todo así que hemos
encontrado dos soluciones con la policía
de antigüedades instalar fuerzas de
seguridad e implicar a los vecinos y
familias que viven allí la policía ya no
debe permitir que la gente entre y tire
su basura esperemos que en un futuro
próximo se protejan estos lugares en
iraka
pide una mayor concienciación pública
sobre el patrimonio arqueológico y otras
voces reclaman la vigilancia por
satélite de yacimientos remotos en los
últimos años Irán ha conseguido
repatriar varios miles de antigüedades
halladas en Estados Unidos y Europa pero
al mismo tiempo el tráfico de artefactos
no parece frenarse según la UNESCO
representa una ganancia financiera de 10
mil millones de dólares anuales en el
mundo